pêcheurs et il y en a une autre qui a
été énorme ici ailleurs a franchement je
vous jure j'en ai pleuré de rien c'est
kelly qui a piégé une salle d'attenté
d'un centre médical et kelly est sujette
à des flatulences jamais regardé ça
c'est très très fort c'est dans la
grande race sera 3 regarder
si tu vas les assumer
[Musique]
et
les doigts
[Musique]
non
enfin
r
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui ça va merci beaucoup raté
moi oui je sens aussi mais c'est pas mal
la fois
[Applaudissements]
ça fait un moment un peu plus
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bon là c'est bon non mais c'est pas moi
c'est pas moi madame août alors c'est
comme ça c'est bon bah ouais ça va mal
[Rires]
non c'est pas ma faute
ça vous énerve aussi madame somme energy
star r on a grandi
oui je sais madame en raison des causes
mais madame je ne suis pas agressif mais
ces déserts désolé je suis très choquée
votre attitude
les patients sont malades oui ce qu'ils
peuvent travailler dans le médical quand
vous avez écrit d'aérophagie faut passer
ça que retourner 5-0 entérologue qu'il
faut qu'elles vont être dites
je sais pas fonctionner vos réserves ça
sans quoi le congo a pas ça sent pas la
caméra cachée des mots
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
alors alors je voulais que le procédé
elle elle fait très bien la mosquée mais
si c'est son meilleur rôle à baa3
maintenant qu'elle pelle dans la vie
tranquille non mais alors et on avait
mis un ampli en fait sous le siège à
envoyer des pays il y avait pas d'odeur
ligne à dos d'homme c'est psychologique
je ne jure que c'est vrai les jo il
était passé on avait une odeur c'est
vraiment c'est de cette île relie le
bruit et l'odeur
ah ouais il redit le bruit et l'odeur
mais c'est comme dans ma bouche je vais
vous dire quoi ah ah ah parce que vous
êtes très bonne non justement on voulait
me on m'avait demandé de le faire et
malheureusement d'emploi du temps
c'était pas possible mais j'aurais
jamais et entend y aura pas eu besoin de
mission
les